مع كل حدث كبير في المملكة
المتحدة يظهر فيها التاج
بياخد حقه بدراعه. وزارة العدل
الامريكية تصادر هواتف كبار
على ما اسمته استفزازات ارمينية
تركية مستمرة في دعم اذربيجان
هذا الاجتماع المرتقب? طائرات
اصحاب العيون الضيقة تتوغل في
متشبثون بها. ولن نتخذ اي سياسات
لاسترضاء موسكو. وكيف ستدفئين
هنا المتحدث باسم الرئاسة
التركية يؤكد ان الاشتباكات على
تعلن وفاتها الاشتباكات المتجددة
بين اذربيجان وارمينيا فقد اظهر
باربع وعشرين طائرة صينية وخمس
سفن عسكرية عبرت الفاصلة لمضيق
الالكتروني. اجتماع مرتقب قد
يبشر بولادة قرارات تاريخية
بوتين. ولا ننسى حفيد ارطغرل باب
بوتين يحمل ملفات اوكرانيا
تحسن العلاقات بين البلدين. فما
رأيكم انتم؟ اوكرانيا تقول
الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ مع
وبرفقة كبير الدبلوماسيين
مستشاري الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب لجمع معلومات حول
الغاز الروسي الذي تسبب بمجاعة
طاقة في دول اوروبا. رئيسة
الصينيين يمجيتشي ووزير الخارجية
وانجي. اظن ان الموضوع اشد خطورة
الكابتشينو الخاصة بك يا
اورسولا. اجتماع عاجل. اطارات
العربية المقررة في الجزائر مطلع
نوفمبر المقبل وهو ما يشير الى
الطموحات تؤكد على اهمية استمرار
العمليات العسكرية التي تقوم بها
فاذا استمر الضخ غير المقيد
لنظام كييف باخطر انواع الاسلحة
شروطها حتى قبل ان تطلبها موسكو
ليرد الروس على امريكا متجاهلين
الملك البريطاني مسروقة من شعوب
اخرى مقتل ضابط اسرائيلي
الخارجية التركي مولود شاوش
اوغلو ارمينيا للاستفادة من فرصة
ملوك بريطانيا منذ عام الف
وثمانمائة وخمسين حتى زينة تاج
الاعلام خبرا عن مشاركة العاهل
المغربي الملك محمد السادس القمة
وهددت بحرق نفسها حال عدم
تسليمها وديعتها لمعالجة شقيقتها
الاوكران. بينما واشنطن تحضر
لعقوبات الصين على نار هادئة.
بالانضمام الى الناتو. ليأتي
الرد من الكرملين. طموح اوكرانيا
هنا منصات صواريخ اسكندر الروسية
لا ينطفئ لهيبها وتحلق. وازيز
وفلسطينيين اثنين في هجوم مسلح
شمال جنيف. تداولت عدد من وسائل
يتعين على الدول الموقعة على
الضمانات الامنية الاوكرانية
ليظهر هنا ان سلاحها لم يكن الا
لعبة. اولك يدلع الازعر اللي
المريضة بسرطان. وبعد ان تمكنت
من قبض عشرين الف دولار اوقف
تشهد حاليا نقطة تحول ام لا.
وهنا نضع الف علامة تعجب
الحدود الاذربيجانية الارمينية
تبعث على القلق فيما دعا وزير
ومؤكدا ان بلاده لن تتحرك بمعزل
عن اذربيجان. اما فيما يتعلق
البريطاني مطالب الهند باعادة
ماسة كوهنور التي تزين تيجان
السلام التي اعقبت حرب كارباغ
الاخيرة متهم باستفزاز اذربيجان
تايوان ام انها ستنفذه بعد الغزو
كما فعلت مع اوكرانيا. تركيا
فيه. وتابع ميدفيديف انه حينها
لن تتمكن الدول الغربية من
اليونان لاخذ العبر من التاريخ
وعدم الدخول في مغامرات جديدة
تصرفات ترامب في انتخابات الفين
وعشرين واحداث اقتحام الكونجرس.
بالصراع مع اليونان دعا وزير
الدفاع التركي خلوصي ابكار
اوكرانيا اذ تنص الوثيقة على ان
الدول الضامنة وعلى رأسها
للانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
سيبقى تهديدا لروسيا. هذه
الامن العام اللبناني المودعة
المسلحة التي اقتحمت المصرف
جديدة تكون كازاخستان هي الحاضنة
لها. برأيكم ما الذي سيخرج به
برقدار التركية. وكانت اذربيجان
اعلنت اشتباكات حدودية مكثفة ردا
اليوناني? الاحداث تطورات. ما
بقى عندي شي اخسروا. وصلنا
وفرنسا واستراليا وتركيا
بالاضافة الى دول شمال اوروبا
تقديم المساعدة لكييف في حال
تعرضها لاعتداء. واشار نص مسودة
ويرتبط بقرارات مصيرية حملة
الانتقام لن تكتمل الا بحضور
الوثيقة الى ان الضمانات الامنية
ليست بديلا عن طموح اوكرانيا
على حد وصفه. برأيكم هل ستؤثر
حرب اذربيجان على الصراع التركي
تدخل الحرب. وبعد ولادة هدنة هشة
لم تستمر او تعيش لساعات. ها هي
للاخير. هذا ما قالته مسلحة
لبنانية اقتحمت مصرفا في بيروت
على الاتحاد الاوروبي لاعداد
حزمة عقوبات محتملة على الصين
مقطع فيديو قصفا اذربيجانيا على
مواقع عسكرية ارمينية بمسيرة
تايوان. وسفنهم الحربية تقترب من
جحيم الحرب بكين تصعد وتايباد
ودول البلطيق واوروبا الوسطى
والشرقية. وبموجب مسودة الوثيقة
تستعد. اذ اعلنت وزارة الدفاع
التايوانية عن اختراق صيني جديد
الصين عن غزو تايوان. وبحسب ما
افادت وكالة رويترز تايوان تضغط
الحملة العسكرية سيناريو عسكريا
خاصا بها يتضمن مشاركين جددا
تايوان. لترد هنا واشنطن وتتحدث
عن عقوبات مبكرة الهدف منها ردع
واستفهام مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
زيلانسكي يكشف عن مسودة امنية
المفوضية الاوروبية تصرح
العقوبات ضد روسيا باقية ونحن
بينما اصحاب العيون الضيقة
يحملون ملف تيوان ورقائقها
والغاز الروسي واردوغان يحمل ملف
الازمة السورية وعداوة اليونان.
الولايات المتحدة وبريطانيا
وكندا وبولندا وايطاليا والمانيا
الضمانات الامنية. وفي الواقع
مقدمة للحرب العالمية الثالثة.
العملية طويلة الامد. واضاف
الرئيس الامريكي في تصريحات
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تصرح انها
دمرت مراكز عمليات وبنى تحتية
وذلك بطلب رسمي من وزير الخارجية
التايواني. فهل تلبي واشنطن طلب
عندئذ ستنتقل الحملة العسكرية ام
اجلا الى مستوى اخر. وستتبع
اولف شولز يحث الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين على حل دبلوماسي
ديمتري ميدفيديف نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي والذي قال مشروع
الاستراتيجية والتي تقع في
مقاطعة خركيف. بينما يظهر هنا
من سخونة المحركات ولكنها ليست
اسخن من الملفات التي حملها
كل شيء من حولهم سيشتعل حسب
تعبيره. ومن البارود الى رائحة
الهدف ايصال رسالة لبوتين ام
ماذا? نعم فقد ظهرت صور للرئيس
الجلوس في منازلها لتضحك على
كيفية اضعافها لروسيا للوكالة.
روسيا على الاراضي الاوكرانية.
ليعزز بعدها برد اخر وبلسان
للصحفيين في ولاية انه من غير
الممكن معرفة ما اذا كانت الحرب
هنازلينسكي ومن امام خط المواجهة
مع روسيا. ماذا يفعل هناك? هل
تحت عنوان معاهدة كييف الامنية
تتعهد بها الدول الضامنة امام
العجوز الطاعن في السن الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن. من الواضح ان
والتحكم بالقرارات الداخلية وعلى
رأسها الانتخابات الامريكية عام
الاوكرانيين حققوا تقدما ميدانيا
كبيرا غير اني اتوقع ان تكون
طائرته تحط وتلامس الاراضي
الكازاخستانية نعم طائرته تشكو
مهلا اني اسمع هاتف بوتين يرن
نعم في مكالمة هاتفية استمرت
اجانب في اكثر من اربع وعشرين
دولة. والهدف كسب النفوذ فيها
من خمسمائة مليون دولار سرا
لحسابات احزاب سياسية ومرشحين
ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي دعما
لدونالد ترامب والذي اعرب عن
اعجابه بالرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين حينها. ومن الحروب
ازمة الطاقة وارتفاع الاسعار
بشكل جنوني. لتدخل على الخط
شوارع الدول الاوروبية
بالمظاهرات والاحتجاجات والسبب
الاوكرانية والذي مكنها من تحقيق
تقدم كبير في خركيب ليظهر
هجوم عنيف مختلف محاور القتال في
جنوبي وشمالي شرق اوكرانيا.
الاوكراني زيلينسكي اثناء زيارته
المفاجئة لمدينة ازيوم
الطائرات الروسية لا يصمت ولا
نعلم ماذا تخبئ تحت اجنحتها.
اعلام غربية عن وجود مخاوف
امريكية من انقسام في اوروبا
الامريكية تصادر هواتف ترامب
الهند تحرج بريطانيا بهذا الطلب
عسكرية اوكرانية ياتي ذلك ردا
على الهجوم الصادم للقوات
قبل دفن الملكة اليزابيث
الثانية. لهيب المعارك لا ينطفئ.
فما هو سر هذا الاجتماع بينما
المانيا تطلب طلبها الاخير من
تجاه التعاطي مع روسيا في ظل
تفاقم ازمة الطاقة لتتفجر هنا
الاستخبارات الامريكية تكشف سر
روسيا الاخطر وواشنطن تتحضر
لتسعين دقيقة مع بوتين المتحدث
باسم الحكومة الالمانية المستشار
الاستخباراتية تأخذنا رائحة
البارود الى الحروب العسكرية.
اذا اردت السلام فاستعد للحرب.
ويا لها من حرب لا تخمد نارها
بوتين. الرئيس الاوكراني يغضب
الروس بشروط جديدة وموسكو ترد.
الفين وستة عشر. وذلك من خلال
استخدام قوة امنها السيبراني
الاستخبارات الامريكية حيث رفعت
السرية عن تقارير وصفت بالخطيرة
تتحدث عن عمليات روسية بعدة دول.
وقالت ان روسيا قامت بارسال اكثر
لمعاقبة بكين ليأتي الرد في
سواحل تايوان. بينما وزارة العدل
فهل سيصمت اصحاب العيون الضيقة
يقوم على وقف اطلاق النار وسحب
قواته من اوكرانيا لتكشف وسائل
ولا يختفي دخانها. الرئيس الصيني
يصل اولا لينتظر بوتين واردوغان.